This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, This is Chris
Abraham.
Chris Abraham Show season five,
episode 38.
Is it 38?
I'm not sure.
I think it's 38.
And I caught my body healing
last night.
It was weird.
Like, I know it's not what was
happening.
It was that.
My knee was sore and it had been
inflamed and that over the
course of my sleep the
inflammation decreased and I,
you know, bent my knee and all
that other stuff and then then
it went away.
But in my weird dream space, I
believed that over the course
tonight, the abuse that I've
been putting my body in with
regards to bye, bye bye.
The abuse that I put my body in
with this 30 pound plate and all
the stuff inside.
I woke up in the middle of the
night.
My Mama says, What you going to
do with your life?
Oh baby dear, I know you're
still #1.
And girls, they want to have
fun.
Oh girls just want to have fun.
So I woke up in the middle of
the night and my knee was like
really sore and like, I'm afraid
about my knees not dealing well
with this.
You know, I think it's like 24
kilogram bag now.
And I'm using these Whiten or
Witten minimalist shoes, cheap
shoes off of Amazon because I
don't want too much cushion
because I'm afraid of imbalance
or.
Twisting my ankle or something
like that.
So I took an extra long walk
yesterday, but only, you know,
with this new weight.
I've only been doing like 8 to
10,000 steps and I want to do
14,000 steps, but I'm adapting
from a 20 pound plate to a 30
pound plate, so I don't want to
overdo it.
Also, it's humid and hot here in
DCI.
Think it gets up.
Gets up to 90.
I don't know, 88 to 86.
It's not that hot.
I don't feel it that much, but
even though I don't seem to feel
it that much, like my sniper
boony funny hat sure does get
sweaty, so I know that happens.
So I woke up in the middle of
the night, my mom.
So I won't do that again to you.
And my knee was like, I was like
so stiff and awful.
And I folded myself into sort of
a a, an embryo kind of curled up
kind of thing in my bed and went
back to sleep.
And when I woke up, my legs felt
terrific, right?
And I.
I make myself stay in bed for
like 8 or 9 hours, which ends up
being six 7-8 hours of actual
sleep according to my Fitbit and
my Garmin.
So I give myself plenty of time
and when I wake up I guzzle
water and electrolytes.
And I've been eating only
carnivore, so only protein and
fat, and I know that helps with
recovery and with all this
walking and so forth, my heart
rate is down.
My resting heart rate is like
56586162 and so that's good for
my sleep and my recovery.
And even Garmin, which never
ever gives me any body battery.
They tend to always just like
steal body battery.
I actually got a huge body
battery boost overnight so I
obviously slept well and my HRV
was good, but it was pretty
amazing.
Like to feel like I woke up in
the middle of the night.
I'm like, Oh my God, I effed up
like.
I broke myself, like my legs are
traumatized from all this
walking with all this weight.
And I woke up really like
thinking that, really feeling
that.
And and then when I woke up in
the morning, everything felt
like completely peachy.
And so I'm like, I caught you
body, I caught you, I caught you
healing and recovering.
And now I understand the extreme
value.
Of sleep, because that only
happens really during sleep.
So get your sleep, kiddos.
Honestly, if you don't
prioritize sleep in your life,
you're an asshole, right?
Like these people.
I got the such the wrong idea
during when I was 16 with close
up study tour we met with.
My senator, Senator Inouye.
And he was like, I only need
five hours of sleep every night.
I just get five hours of sleep
now.
I lived in a world where I
thought people didn't bullshit
or didn't lie or didn't talk
crap.
So I feel like if someone told
me something, I believed them.
I still believe you if you tell
me something.
But I always put little asterisk
by things that I think are lies
or bullshit.
And I feel like someone who is a
high level athlete or a high
level bodybuilder or a I feel
like these people are secretly
like long sleepers.
I feel like they take recovery
as seriously because I've
started to see like these
fulltime athletes.
You know people who are
underwritten by Olympics money
or by Nike or Brooks or whoever,
whomever Hoka, they have time
during the day.
People practicing for the
Olympics take daytime naps and
they sleep and they they will do
one workout in the morning.
And they will go home, they will
eat and then they will freaking
crash and then they will do,
they will do a a second workout,
they'll have dinner and then
they'll go to.
Then they'll go to bed, they'll
go to bed.
So I feel like high level
athletes watch too much Andrew
Tate and feel like that if
they're not fronting.
If they're not making people
feel like they're super people
by saying that they don't need a
baby's level of nine hours of
sleep a night to recover from,
you know, £1000 deadlifts, here
comes a big truck.
I'm sure this is the one that
goes by every day.
There's wind and there's trucks.
And so, like, this is going to
be a terrible episode.
But the good news is, is that
this is a terrible episode
anyway.
But I am walking with my camel.
Sorry, my coyote.
Brown.
I keep on wanting to say it's
Narnia, but there's a type of of
giant, giant rodent.
I saw one of them in Portland,
OR.
It's a Nubia Nubia.
No, that's that's a an African
woman.
All I can think of is Narnia
nutria.
So nutria is a color, and nutria
is the exact color.
I think is what other countries
called coyote brown.
And I just call it 10 or khaki.
But calling something khaki is
khaki cool, not tactical.
And that's not cool at all.
So yeah, I'm walking with it.
I've got my chest rig.
It's.
Gray runners kit bag in rip stop
nylon and it's I think the
medium size maybe becomes
another truck.
This is fun.
What would Jesus do?
This is so much fun.
I think it's always fun to do
podcasts this way because
honestly, I don't want anybody
to listen.
So if I have blah blah blah
podcasts like this.
Maybe someone will listen to be
like, I'm not going to listen to
that, Listen to all that wind
and all that Yammer and all that
street noise.
It's crazy.
Who would listen to that?
Fair enough.
So I did sign up to be a tail,
tail, runner tail, whatever for
the park run this Saturday.
So I have to be there.
At 08/30 and I'm biking there
and then afterwards I'm going to
join them for coffee.
And then who knows what I'll do
next.
Maybe I'll go to Courthouse and
watch the Barbie movie.
Anyway, everything's so crazy.
I think I'll call it a day and
I'll talk to you tomorrow.
Take care and Aloha.
Bye, bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes
until next time.